اهلا بكم في بلاد النشره والتغطيه التي
نخصصها لهذه الكلمه للامن العام لحلفي
شمال الاطلسيه البركه
[موسيقى]
جاستن والدينا امم بتحليلات تمهيديه تشير
الى الناس ربما بان هذا الحادث كان بسبب
صاروخا من النظام الدفاع
الاوكرانيه في مواجهه
الصواريخ الروسيه لنكن واضحين هنا
هذا الخطا وليس
خطارانها
روسيا هي التي تحمل في نهايه المطاف
لانها تستمر في حربها غير المشروعه ضد
اوكرانيا خلال اجتماع اليوم حلفاء الحلفاء
قدموا تعازيهم
عن تضامنهم مع هذا الحديث
ان تتوقف عن هذه الحرب التي لا معنى لها
تحدثت مع همم الرئيس البولندي والرئيس
الامريكي
واتفقنا بانه ينبغي ان نتحلى بالهدوء
والحرص والتنسيق ونحن سنستمر في مراقبه
الاوضاع عن كثب ان الحلفه متحد
ونحن سنقوم بكل ما يجب من اجل دفاعي عن
جميع حلفائنا لكم الاسئله
سؤال من الاذاعه البولنديه تفضلي
السيد الامير
هل نتوقع تعزيزا اللي انظمه الدفاع الجوي
للبلدان
الاوكرانيه في اجتماع اليوم
اعلن الحلفاء
بانهم
يدعمونمون بولندا
وكماروا
هذه الخساره في الارواح
وان الحلفه قد عزل وجوده في هذه المنطقه
والاسيه منذ الغدر الروسي لاوكرانيا
لا بريه
ايضا للقوات الجويه والبحريه هذا الامر
ساهم في تعزيز القدرات اا انضم الارتفاع
الجوي وايضا قدرات المراقبه
وحتى تكون لدينا فكره واضحه بشان ما يحدث
بين حدود
مع اوكرانيا
نستمر في النظر لما ينبع القيام به
ولقد اخذنا قراءه قويه في قمه مدريد في ما
يتعلق بتعزيز وقدرتنا في الجناح الشرقيه
سؤال سؤال بي سي
الاكثر حجه
هل هناك في هذا النزاع مع الحلف انا احاول
دائما ان اكون حذرا ولا اقوم بتصنيفا
بتصنيفا للاحداث
وهذا يبين بان الحرب في اوكرانيا
المسؤوليه الرئيس بوتين
وهذه حرب
المرحله
خطيره وعلينا ان نقول بانها روسيا قد اشنت
هذه الهجمات الصاروخيه ضد المدن
الاوكرانيه
اهداف المدنيه
هو امر خطير
لان تكون تداعيات على اراضي الحلت دعايات
هذه الحرب التي شنتها روسيا ضد اوكرانيا
سؤال من وكاله الانباء الاوكرانيه
لدى شعب البولندي
ان هذا الحدث يبين ويبين اهميه الدعم في
مجال الدفاع الجوي من الحلفاء الى همم
الى اوكرانيا مدى عن الحظر الجويه
يعني الامر يتعلق هنا
[موسيقى]
الدفاع الجوي ولا سيما ان روسيا قد شنت
حمله ضد المدن الاوكرانيه